[Music]
office in bucks county in this key state
of pennsylvania
we found confusion and frustration i
work in a nursing home
half of our residents not receive a
ballot yet so i'm
waiting in line to try to get their
ballots
just tell me why you're here this
morning because i never
received my mail-in ballot so what's the
process
you you apply for a mail in balance and
then they send it to you in the post
yes but that didn't happen no the
same issue for you yes absolutely and we
checked before we came down here and
still they have no record of us
requesting a ballot
most of these people had already voted
or thought they had and they called you
today and said come down
took it that took that long for them to
let me know there was a problem
statewide they've already received two
and a half million male 1
absentee ballots that's 10 times the
number in 2016
and that's the problem this is not a
place where voters or officials
are used to this process they're only
opting for it because of the pandemic
[Music]
on a screen into a secure room election
official larry king
shows us the challenge ahead these are
the envelopes that will be open
starting at at seven o'clock tomorrow
morning
um this is the ballot sorting machine we
call it the dragon
you basically feed the ballots in here
and they're able to sort
by the bar codes on the envelope in all
of these are ballots that have already
been
cast all here and and these over here
you see how long it takes yeah
absolutely so multiply that process
by 150 000 and that's what
that's what we're up against this is a
swing county in a swing state
president trump lost it narrowly last
time and he spent the past few months
questioning the viability of the process
and suggesting he won't wait days for
the votes to be counted
the president can declare whatever the
president can whether it's legal or not
is uh is another matter hi michelle
hi did you manage to sort out the
problem i did
they gave me a new ballot i voted put it
in the secrecy envelope put it in the
big envelope and hand it
in and how does it feel to avoid it
feels wonderful
this is an indication then of a stretch
process in an election like no other
the results here in pennsylvania at
least will take some time
mark stone sky news in bucks county